the following is a conversation with
raha Prasad he's the vice president and
head scientist of Amazon Alexa and one
of its original creators the Alexa team
embodies some of the most challenging
incredible impactful and inspiring work
that is done in a high today the team
has to both solve problems at the
cutting edge of natural language
processing and provide a trustworthy
secure and enjoyable experience to
millions of people this is where
state-of-the-art methods in computer
science meet the challenges of
real-world engineering in many ways
Alexa and the other voice assistants are
the voices of artificial intelligence to
millions of people and an introduction
to AI for people who have only
encountered it in science fiction this
is an important and exciting opportunity
so the work that Rohit and the Alexa
team are doing is an inspiration to me
and to many researchers and engineers in
the AI community this is the artificial
intelligence podcast if you enjoy it
subscribe on YouTube give it five stars
an apple podcast supported on patreon or
simply connect with me on Twitter Alex
Friedman spelled Fri D ma n if you leave
a review on an apple podcast especially
but also cast box or comment on youtube
consider mentioning topics people ideas
questions quotes in science tech or
philosophy that you find interesting and
I'll read them on this podcast I won't
call out names but I love comments with
kindness and thoughtfulness in them so I
thought I'd share them someone on
YouTube highlighted a quote from the
conversation with Ray Dalio
where he said that you have to
appreciate all the different ways that
people can be a player's this connected
me to on teams of engineers it's easy to
think that raw productivity is the
measure of excellence but there are
others I've worked with people who
brought a smile to my face every time I
got to work in the morning their
contribution to the team is immeasurable
I recently started doing podcast ads at
the end of the introduction I'll do one
or two minutes after introducing the
episode and never any ads in the middle
that break the flow of the conversation
I hope that works for you it doesn't
hurt the listening experience this show
is presented by cash app the number one
finance app in the App Store I
personally use cash app to send money to
friends but you can also use it to buy
sell and deposit a big coin in just
seconds cash app also has a new
investing feature you can buy fractions
of a stock say $1 worth no matter what
the stock price is brokerage services
are provided by cash up investing a
subsidiary of square and member at CIBC
I'm excited to be working with cash app
to support one of my favorite
organizations called first best known
for their first robotics and Lego
competitions they educate and inspire
hundreds of thousands of students in
over 110 countries and have a perfect
rating at Charity Navigator which means
the donated money is used to maximum
effectiveness when you get cash app from
the App Store Google Play and use code
Lex podcast you'll get $10 and cash app
will also donate $10 to 1st which again
is an organization that I've personally
seen inspire girls and boys the dream of
engineering better world this podcast is
also supported by a zip recruiter hiring
great people is hard and to me is one of
the most important elements of
successful mission driven team I've been
fortunate to be a part of and lead
several great engineering teams the
hiring I've done in the past was mostly
through tools we built ourselves but
reinventing the wheel was painful sip
recruiters a tool that's already
available for you it seeks to make
hiring simple fast and smart
for example codable co-founder gretchen
[ __ ] nner use zip recruiter to find a
new game artist to join our education
tech company by using sip recruiters
screening questions to filter candidates
Gretchen found it easier to focus on the
best candidates and finally hiring the
perfect person for the role in less than
two weeks from start to finish
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
CY zip recruiters effective for
businesses of all sizes by signing up as
I did for free at zip recruiter comm /
Lex
pod that
zipper Kirkham / Lex pod and now here's
my conversation with Rohit Prasad in the
movie her I'm not sure if you ever seen
a human falls in love with a voice of an
AI system let's start at the highest
philosophical level before we get too
deep learning and some of the fun things
do you think this what the movie her
shows is within our reach
I think not specifically about her but I
think what we are seeing is a massive
increase in adoption of AI assistants
Rai and all parts of our social fabric
and I think it's what I do believe is
that the utility these areas provide
some of the functionalities that are
shown are absolutely within reach so the
some of the functionality in terms of
the interactive elements but in terms of
the deep connection that's purely voice
based do you think such a close
connection as possible with voice alone
it's been a while since I saw her but I
would say in terms of the in terms of
interactions which are both human-like
and in these AI assistants you have to
value what is also super human we as
humans can be in only one place
AI assistance can be in multiple places
at the same time one with you on your
mobile device one at your home one at
work so you have to respect these
superhuman capabilities to Plus as
humans we have certain attributes we are
very good at where you're at reasoning
AI assistance not yet there but in
Terrell mauve AI assistance what they're
great at is computation memory it's
infinite and pure these are the
attributes you have to start respecting
so I think the comparison with
human-like versus the other aspect which
is also super human has to be taken into
consideration so I think we need to
elevate the discussion to not just human
like so there's certainly elements we
just mentioned
Alexa's everywhere computation is
speaking so this is a much bigger
infrastructure than just the thing that
sits there
in the room with you but it certainly
feels to us mere humans that there's
just another little creature there when
you're interacting with it you're not
interacting with the entirety of the
infrastructure you're interacting with
the device the feeling is okay sure we
anthropomorphize things but that feeling
is still there so what do you think we
as humans the purity of the interaction
with a smart assistant what do you think
we look for in that interaction I think
in the certain interactions I think will
be very much where it does feel like a
human because it has a persona of its
own and in certain ones it wouldn't be
so I think a simple example to think of
it is if you're walking through the
house and you just want to turn on your
lights on and off and you're issuing a
command that's not very much like a
human-like interaction and that's where
the AI shouldn't come back and have a
conversation with you just it should
simply complete that command so those I
think the blend of we have to think
about this is not human human alone it
is a human machine interaction and
certain aspects of humans are needed and
certain aspects are in situations demand
it to be like a machine so I told you
it's gonna be full soft cause in parts
what was the difference between human
and machine in that interaction when we
interact to humans especially those our
friends and loved ones versus you and a
machine that you also are close with I
think they you have to think about the
roles the AI plays right so and it
differs from different customer to
customer different situation to
situation especially I can speak from
Alexis perspective it is a companion a
friend at times an assistant an advisor
down the line so I think most a eyes
will have this kind of attributes and it
will be very situational in nature so
where is the boundary I think the
boundary depends on exact context in
which you are interacting what they are
so the depth and the richness of natural
language conversation is been by Alan
Turing being used to try to define what
it means to be intelligent you know
there's a lot of criticism of that kind
of
but what do you think it's a good test
of intelligence in your view in the
context of the Turing test and Alexa or
the elect surprise this whole realm do
you think about this human intelligence
what it means to define it what it means
to reach that level I do think the
ability to converse is an sign of an
ultimate intelligence I think that is no
question about it so if you think about
all aspects of humans there are sensors
we have and those are basically a data
collection mechanism and based on that
we make some decisions with our sensory
brains right and from that perspective I
think that there are elements we have to
talk about how we sense the world and
then how we act based on what we sense
those elements clearly machines have but
then there's the other aspects of
computation that is way better I also
mentioned about memory again in terms of
being near infinite depending on the
storage capacity you have and the
retrieval can be extremely fast and pure
in terms of like there's no ambiguity of
who did I see when right I mean if your
machine scan remember that quite well so
it again on a philosophical level I do
subscribe to the fact that to can be
able to converse and as part of that to
be able to reason based on the world
knowledge you've acquired and the
sensory knowledge that is there is
definitely very much the essence of
indulgence but indulgence can go beyond
human level intelligence based on what
machines are getting capable of so what
do you think maybe stepping outside of
Alexa broadly as an AI field what do you
think is a good test of intelligence put
it another way outside of Alexa because
so much of Alexa is a product is an
experience for the customer on the
research side what would impress the
heck out of you if you saw you know what
is the test what he said wow this thing
is now starting to encroach into the
realm of what we loosely think of as
human intelligence so well we think of
it as a GI and human intelligence all
together right so in some sense and I
think we are quite
far from that I think an unbiased view I
have is that the Alexus intelligence
capability is a great test I think of it
as there are many other proof points
like self-driving cars game playing like
go or chess let's take those two for as
an exemption clearly requires a lot of
data-driven learning and intelligence
but it's not as hard a problem as
conversing with as an AI is with it
humans to accomplish certain tasks or
open domain chat as you mentioned like a
surprise in those settings the key
difference is that the end goal is not
defined
unlike game playing you also do not know
exactly what state you are in in a
particular goal completion scenario in
certain times sometimes you can if it is
a simple goal but if you're even certain
examples like planning a weekend or you
can imagine how many things change along
the way you look for whether you make
change your mind and you you change
their destination or you want to catch a
particular event and then you decide no
I want this other event I want to go to
so these dimensions of how many
different steps are possible when you're
conversing as a human with a machine
makes it an extremely daunting problem
and I think it is the ultimate test for
intelligence and don't you think the
natural language is enough to prove that
conversation your conversation from a
scientific standpoint natural language
is a great test but I would go beyond I
don't want to limit it to as natural
language as simply understanding an
intent or parsing for entities and so
forth we are really talking about
dialogue
so so I would say human machine dialogue
is definitely one of the best tests of
intelligence
so can you briefly speak to the Alexa
prize for people who are not familiar
with it and and also just maybe were
things stand and what have you learned
what's surprising what have you seen the
surprising from this incredible
competition absolutely it's a very
competition like surprise is essentially
Grand Challenge in conversational
artificial intelligence where we threw
the gauntlet to the universities who do
active research in the field to say can
you build what we call a social board
that can converse with you coherently
and engagingly for 20 minutes that is an
extremely hard challenge talking to
someone in a who you're meeting for the
first time or even if you're you've met
them quite often to speak at 20 minutes
on any topic an evolving nature of
topics is super hard we have completed
two successful years of the competition
the first was one with the industry of
Washington's second industry of
California we are in our third instance
we have an extremely strong team of 10
cohorts and the third instance of the of
the lexer prizes underway now and we are
seeing a constant evolution first year
was definitely learning it was a lot of
things to be put together we had to
build a lot of infrastructure to enable
these you know STIs to be able to build
magical experiences and and do high
quality research just a few quick
questions sorry for the interruption
what is failure look like in the
20-minute session so what does it mean
to fail not to reach the twenty minimum
awesome question so there are one first
of all I forgot to mention one more
detail it's not just 20 minutes but the
quality of the conversation too that
matters and the beauty of this
competition before I answer that
question on what failure means is first
that you actually converse with millions
and millions of customers as these
social BOTS so during the judging phases
there are multiple phases before we get
to the finals which is a very controlled
judging in a situation where we have we
bring in judges and we have interactors
who interact with these social BOTS that
is a much more controlled setting but
till the point we get to the finals all
the judging is essentially by the
customers of Alexa and there you
basically rate on a simple question how
good your experience was so that's where
we are not testing for a 20 minute
boundary being claw across because you
do want
to be very much like a clear-cut winner
be chosen and and it's an absolute bar
so did you really break that 20-minute
barrier is why we have to test it in a
more controlled setting with actors
essentially in tractors and see how the
conversation goes so this is why it's a
subtle difference between how it's being
tested in the field with real customers
versus in the lab to award the prize so
on the latter one what it means is that
essentially the that there are three
judges and two of them have to say this
conversation is stalled essentially got
it and the judges the human experts
judges or human experts okay great so
this is in the third year so what's been
the evolution how far it's in the DARPA
challenge in the first year the
autonomous vehicles nobody finished in
the second year a few more finished in
the desert so how far along within this
I would say much harder challenge are we
this challenge has come a long way do
they extend that we've definitely not
close to the 20-minute barrier being
with coherence and engaging conversation
I think we are still five to ten years
away in that horizon to complete that
but the progress is immense like what
you're finding is the accuracy in what
kind of responses these social BOTS
generate is getting better and better
what's even amazing to see that now
there's humor coming in the bots are
quite you know you're talking about
ultimate science of intial and signs of
intelligence I think humor is a very
high bar in terms of what it takes to
create humor and I don't mean just being
goofy I really mean good sense of humor
is also a sign of intelligence in my
mind and something very hard to do so
these social BOTS are now exploring not
only what we think of natural language
abilities but also personality
attributes and aspects of when to inject
an appropriate joke went to when you
don't know the question the domain how
you come back with something more
intelligible so that you can continue
the conversation if if you and I are
talking about AI and we are domain
experts we can speak to it but if you
suddenly switch the topic to that I
don't know how do I change the
conversation so you're starting to
notice these elements as well and that's
coming from partly by by the nature of
the 20 minute challenge that people are
getting quite clever on how to really
converse and
essentially masks some of the
understanding defects if they exist so
some of this this is not a Lex of the
products this is somewhat for fun for
research for innovation and so on I have
a question sort of in this modern era
there's a lot of you look at Twitter and
Facebook and so on there's there's
discourse public discourse going on and
some things are a little bit too edgy
people get blocked and so on I'm just
out of curiosity are people in this
context pushing the limits is anyone
using the f-word is anyone sort of
pushing back sort of you know arguing I
guess I should say in as part of the
dialogue to really draw people in first
of all let me just back up a bit in
terms of why we're doing this right so
you said it's fun I think fun is more
part of the engaging part for customers
it is one of the most used skills as
well in our skill store but up that
apart the real goal was essentially what
was happening is with lot of AI research
moving to industry we felt that academia
has the risk of not being able to have
the same resources at disposal that we
have which is loss of beta massive
computing power and a clear ways to test
these AI advances with real customer
benefits so we brought all these three
together in the like surprise that's why
it's one of my favorite projects and
Amazon and with that the secondary fact
is yes it has become engaging for our
customers as well we're not there in
terms of where we want to it to be right
but it's a huge progress but coming back
to your question on how do the
conversations evolve yes there is some
natural attributes of what you said in
terms of argument and some amount of
swearing the way we take care of that is
that there is a sensitive filter we have
built that show you see words and so
it's more than keywords a little more in
terms of of course there's key word base
to but there's more in terms of these
words can be very contextual as you can
see and also the topic can be something
that you don't want a conversation to
happen because this is a criminal device
as well a lot of people use these
devices so we have put
lot of guardrails for the conversation
to be more useful for advancing AI and
not so much of these these other issues
you attributed what's happening in there
I feel as well right so this is actually
a serious opportunity I didn't use the
right word fun I think it's an open
opportunity to do some some of the best
innovation in conversational agents in
in the world absolutely why just
universities why just you know streets
because as I said I really felt young
minds young minds it's also - if you
think about the other aspect of where
the whole industry is moving with AI
there's a dearth of talent in in given
the demands so you do want the
universities to have a clear place where
they can invent and research and not
fall behind with that they can't
motivate students imagine all grad
students left - to industry like us or
or faculty members which has happened -
so this is in a way that if you're so
passionate about the field where you
feel industry and academia need to work
well this is a great example and a great
way for universities to participate so
what do you think it takes to build a
system that wins the allow surprise I
think you have to start focusing on
aspects of reasoning that it is there
are still more lookups of what intense
customers asking for and responding to
those are rather than really reasoning
about the elements of the of the
conversation for instance if you have if
you're playing if the conversation is
about games and it's about a recent
sports event there's so much context in
war and you have to understand the
entities that are being mentioned so
that the conversation is coherent rather
than you suddenly just switch to knowing
some fact about a sports entity and
you're just relating that rather than
understanding the true context of the
game like you if you just said I learned
this fun fact about
Tom Brady rather than really say how he
played the game the previous night then
the conversation is not really that
intelligent so you have to go to more
reasoning elements of understanding the
context of the dialogue and giving more
appropriate responses which tells you
that we are still quite far because a
lot of times it's more facts being
looked after and something that's close
enough as an answer but not really the
answer so that is where the research
needs to go more an actual true
understanding and reasoning and that's
why I feel it's a great way to do it
because you have an engaged set of users
working to make help these AI advances
happen in this case item actually
customers they're there quite a bit and
there's a skill what is the experience
for the for the user that is helping so
just to clarify this isn't as far as I
understand the Alexa so this skill is to
stand alone for the art surprise I mean
it's focused on the elect surprise it's
not you ordering certain things and I
was on the comet trait checking the
weather or you're playing Spotify right
separate skills directly and so you're
focused on helping not well I don't know
how do people how do customers think of
it are they having fun are they helping
teach the system what's the experience
like I think it's both actually and let
me tell you how they how you invoke this
skill so you all you have to say Alexa
let's chat and then the first time you
say Alexa let's chat it comes back with
a clear message that you're interacting
with one of those you know three social
BOTS and there's a fear so he's know
exactly how you interact right and that
is why it's very transparent you are
being asked to help right and and we
have lot of mechanisms where as the we
are in the first phase of feedback phase
then you send a lot of emails to our
customers and then this they know that
this the team needs a lot of
interactions to improve the accuracy of
the system so we know we have lot of
customers who really want to help be
zeros to bots and they are conversing
with that and some are just having fun
with just saying Alexa let's chat and
also some adversarial behavior to see
whether
how much do you understand as a social
bot so I think we have a good healthy
mix of all three situations so what is
the if we talk about solving the Alexa
challenge they like surprise what's the
data set of really engaging pleasant
conversations look like is if we think
of this as a supervised learning problem
I don't know if it has to be but if it
does maybe you can comment on that do
you think there needs to be a data set
of what it means to be an engaging
successful fulfilling copy that's part
of the research question here this was I
think it's we at least got the first
part right which is have a way for
universities to build and test in a
real-world setting now you're asking in
terms of the next phase of questions
which we are still we're also asking by
the way what does success look like from
a optimization function that's what
you're asking in terms of we as
researchers are used to having a great
corpus of annotated data and then making
a Rob then you know sort of tune our
algorithms on those right and
fortunately and unfortunately in this
world of a lexer prize that is not the
way we are going after it so you have to
focus more on learning based on live
feedback that is another element that's
unique we're just not I started with
giving you how you ingress and
experience this capability as a customer
what happens when you're done so they
ask you a simple question on a scale of
one to five how likely are you to
interact with this social bot again that
is a good feedback and customers can
also leave more open-ended feedback and
I think partly that to me is one part of
the question you're asking which I'm
saying is a mental model shift that as
researchers also you have to change your
mindset that this is not a dart by
evaluation or NSF funded study and you
have a nice corpus this is where it's
real world you have real data the scale
is amazing is this
beautiful thing then and then the
customer the user can quit the
conversation in exactly the user game
that is also a signal for how good you
were at that point so and then on a
scale of one to five one two three do
they say how likely are you or is it
just a binary Allah one two five one two
five Wow okay that's such a beautifully
constructed challenge okay you said the
only way to make a smart assistant
really smart to give it eyes and let
explore the world I'm not sure he might
been taken out of context but can you a
comment and I can you elaborate and that
idea is that I personally also find that
ideas super exciting from a social
robotics personal robotics perspective
yeah a lot of things do get taken out of
context my this particular one was just
as philosophically discussion we were
having on terms of what does
intelligence look like and the context
was in terms of learning I think just we
said we as humans are empowered with
many different sensory abilities I do
believe that eyes are an important
aspect of it in terms of if you think
about how we as humans learn it is quite
complex and it's also not unimodal that
you are fed a ton of text or audio and
you just learn that way no you are you
learn by experience you learn by seeing
you're taught by humans and we're very
efficient and how we learn machines on
the contrary are very inefficient on how
they learn especially these AI is I
think the next wave of research is going
to be with less data not just less human
not just with less label data but also
with a lot of week supervision and where
you can increase the learning rate I
don't mean less data in terms of not
having a lot of data to learn from that
we are generating so much data but it is
more about from a aspect of how fast can
you learn so improving the quality of
the data that's the quality data and
learning process I think more on the
learning process I think we have to we
as humans learn with a lot of
noisy data right and and I think that's
the part that I don't think should
change what should change is how we
learn right so if you look at you
mentioned supervised learning we have
making transformative shifts from moving
to more unsupervised more week
supervision those are the key aspects of
how to learn and I think in that setting
you I hope you agree with me that having
other senses is very crucial in terms of
how you learn so absolutely and from a
machine learning perspective which I
hope we get a chance to talk to a few
aspects that are fascinating there but
just stick on the point a sort of a body
you know an embodiment so Alexa has a
body is a very minimalistic beautiful
interface or there's a ring and so on I
mean I'm not sure of all the flavors of
the devices that Alyssa lives on but
there's a minimalistic basic interface
and nevertheless we humans so I have a
Roomba of all kinds of robots and all
over everywhere so what do you think the
Alexa the future looks like if it begins
to shift what his body looks like what
uh what may be beyond the Alexa what do
you think are the different devices in
the home as they start to embody their
intelligence more and more what do you
think that looks like philosophically a
future what do you think that looks I
think let's look at what's happening
today you mentioned I think all our
devices as an Amazon devices we also
wanted to point out Alexa is already
integrated a lot of third-party devices
which also come in lots of forms and
shapes some in robots right some and
microwaves some in appliances of that
you use in everyday life so I think it
is it's not just the shape Alexa takes
in terms of form factors but it's also
where all it's available it's getting in
cars it's getting in different
appliances in homes even toothbrushes
right so I think you have to think about
it is not a physical assistant it will
be in some embodiment
as you said we already have these nice
devices but I think it's also important
to think of it it is a virtual assistant
it does superhuman in the sense that it
is in multiple places at the same time
so I think the the actual embodiment in
some sense to me doesn't matter I think
you have to think of it as not as
human-like and more of what its
capabilities are that derive a lot of
benefit for customers and how there are
different ways to delighted and delight
customers and different experiences and
I think I am a big fan of it not being
in just human like it should be
human-like in certain situations Alexa
Frye social bot in terms of conversation
is a great way to look at it but there
are other scenarios where human like I
think is underselling the abilities of
this AI so if I could trivialize what
we're talking about so if you look at
the way Steve Jobs thought about the
interaction with the device that Apple
produced there was a extreme focus on
controlling the experience by making
sure there's only the Apple produced
devices you see the voice of Alexa being
taking all kinds of forms depending on
what the customers want and that means
that means it could be anywhere from the
microwave to a vacuum cleaner to the
home and so on the voice is the
essential elrom to the interaction I
think voice is an essence it's not all
but it's a key aspect I think to your
question in terms of you should be able
to recognize Alexa and that's a huge
problem I think in terms of a huge
scientific problem I should say like
what are the traits what makes it look
like Alexa especially in different
settings and especially if it's
primarily voice what it is but LX is not
just voice either right I mean we have
devices with a screen now you're seeing
just other behaviors of Alexa so I think
they're in very early stages of what
that means and this will be an important
profit for the following years but I do
believe that being able to recognize and
tell when it's Alexa versus it's not as
going to be important from an Alexa
perspective I'm not speaking for the
entire AI Thank You Marie but from but I
think attribution and as we go into more
of understanding who did what that
identity of the AI is crucial in the
coming world I think from the broad AI
community perspective that's also a
fascinating problem so basically if I
close my eyes and listen to the voice
what would it take for me to recognize
that this is Alexa exactly or at least
the Alexa that I've come to known from
my personal experience in my home
through my interactions that Korea and
the Alexa here in the u.s. is very
different the Alexa and UK and Alexa
India even though they are all speaking
English or the Australian version so
again we're so now think about when you
go into a different culture different
community but you travel there
what do you recognize Alexa I think
these are super hard questions actually
so there's a Tina works on personality
so if we talk about those different
flavours or what it means culturally
speaking India UK u.s. what does it mean
to add so the problem that we just
stated which is fascinating how do we
make it purely recognizable that it's
Alexa assuming that the qualities of the
voice are not sufficient it it's also
the content of what is being said how do
how do we do that how does the
personality kind of come into play
what's what's that researching would
look like it's such a fascinating we
have some very fascinating folks who
from both the UX background and human
factors are looking at these aspects and
these exact questions but I'll
definitely say it's not just how it
sounds the choice of words the tone not
just I mean the voice identity of it but
the tone matters the speed matters how
you speak how you enunciate words how
what choice of words are using how tours
are you or how lending in your
explanations you are all of these are
factors and you also you mentioned
something crucial that it's may have you
may have personalized it Alexa to some
extent in your homes or in the devices
you are interacting with so
you as your individual how you prefer
Alexa sounds can be different than how I
prefer and we may and the amount of
customizability you want to give is also
a key debate we always have but I do
want to point out it's more than the
voice actor that recorded and you'd
sounds like that actor it is more about
the choices of words the attributes of
tonality the volume in terms of how you
raise your pitch and so forth all of
that matters this is a fascinating
problem from a product perspective I
could see those debates just happening
inside of the Alexa team of how much
personalization do you do for the
specific customer because you're taking
a risk if you over personalized because
you don't I
if you create a personality for a
million people you can test that better
you can create a rich fulfilling
experience that will do well but if the
more you personalize it the less you can
test it the less you can know that it's
it's a great experience so how much
personalization what's the right balance
I think the right balance depends on the
customer give them the control so I'd
say I think the more control you give
customers the better it is for everyone
and I'll give you some key
personalization features I think we have
a feature called remember this which is
where you can tell Alexa to remember
something there you have an explicit
sort of control in customers hand
because they have to say like I remember
XYZ what kind of things would that be
used for so you can respond or something
I have stored my tire specs for my car
nice because it's so hard to go and find
and see what it is right when you're
having some issues I store my mileage
plan numbers for all the frequent-flyer
ones where sometimes just looking at it
and it's not handy so and so those are
my own personal choices army for Alexa
to remember something on my behalf right
so again I think the choice was be
explicit about how you provide that to a
customer as a control so I think these
are the aspects of what you do like
think about
where we can use speaker recognition
capabilities that it's if you taught
Alexa that you are Lex and this person
you're householders person to then you
can personalize the experiences again
these are very in this and the CX
customer experience patterns are very
clear about and transparent when a
personalization action is happening and
then you have other ways like you go
through explicit control right now
through your app that your multiple
service providers let's say for music
which one is your preferred one so when
you say place ting depend on your
whether you have preferred Spotify or
Amazon music or Apple music that the
decision is made where to play it from
so what's Alexis backstory from her
perspective this is there I remember
just asking as probably a lot of us are
just the basic questions about love and
so on of Alexa just to see what the
answer would be just as a it feels like
there's a little bit of a back like
there's a feels like there's a little
bit of personality but not too much is
Alexa have a metaphysical presence in
this human universe we live in or is it
something more ambiguous is there a past
is there birth is there family kind of
idea even for joking purposes and so on
I think well it does tell you if I think
you should double-check this but if you
said when were you born I think we do
respond I need to double check that but
I'm pretty positive about it I think you
do it because I think I've too soon but
that's like that's like hell like I was
born in your brand of champagne and
whatever the year good thing yeah so in
terms of the metaphysical I think it's
early does it have the historic
knowledge about herself
to be able to do that maybe have we
crossed that boundary not yet right in
terms of being thank you have you
thought about it quite a bit but I
wouldn't say that we have come to a
clear decision in terms of what it
should look like but you can imagine
though and I bring this back to the
Alexa prize social BOTS one
there you will start seeing some of that
like you these bots have their identity
and in terms of that you may find you
know this is such a great research topic
that some academia team may think of
these problems and start solving them -
so let me ask a question it's kind of
difficult I think but it feels
fascinating to me because I'm fascinated
with psychology it feels that the more
personality you have the more dangerous
it is in terms of a customer perspective
of products if you want to create a
product that's useful by dangerous I
mean creating an experience that upsets
me and so what how do you get that right
because if you look at the relationships
maybe I'm just a screwed-up Russian but
if you look at the real human to human
relationship some of our deepest
relationships have fights have tension
have the push and pull have a little
flavor in them do you want to have such
flavor in an interaction with Alexa how
do you think about that so there's one
other common thing that you didn't say
but is we think of it as paramount for
any deep relationship that's trust trust
yeah so I think if you trust every
attribute you said mm-hmm a fight some
tension yeah is or healthy but the
waters sort of unknowable in this
instance is trust and I think the bar to
earn customer trust for AI is very high
in some sense more than a human it's
it's not just about personal information
or your data it's also about your
actions on a daily basis how trustworthy
are you in terms of consistency in terms
of how accurate are you in understanding
me like if if you're talking to a person
on the phone if you have a problem with
your let's say your internet or
something if the person is not
understanding you lose trust right away
you don't want to talk to that person
that whole example gets amplified by a
factor of 10 because as when you're a
human interacting with an AI you have a
certain expectation either you expect it
to be
very intelligent and then you get upset
why is it behaving this way more you
expect it to be not so intelligent and
when it surprises you're like really
you're trying to be too small so I think
we grapple with these hard questions as
well but I think the key is actions need
to be trustworthy from these a is not
just about data protection your personal
information protection but also from how
accurate it accomplishes all commands
are all interactions well it's tough to
hear because Trust you're absolutely
right but Trust is such a high bar with
AI systems because people and I see this
because I work with autonomous vehicles
I mean the bar this placed on AI system
is unreasonably high yeah that is going
to be as I agree with you and I think of
it is it's it's a challenge and it's
also keeps my job so from that
perspective that I totally I think of it
at both sides as a customer and as a
researcher I think as a researcher yes
occasionally it will frustrate me that
why is the bar so high for these AIS and
as a customer then I say absolutely it
has to be that high right so I think
that's the trade-off we have to balance
but doesn't change the fundamentals that
trust has to be own and the question
then becomes is are we holding the AIS
to a different bar and accuracy and
mistakes then we hold humans that's
going to be a great societal questions
for years to come I think for us well
one of the questions that we grapple as
a society now that I think about a lot I
think a lot of people know I think about
a lot and Alexis taking on head-on is
privacy is the reality is us giving over
data to any AI system can be used to
enrich our lives in in in profound ways
so if maybe basically any product that
does anything awesome for you would the
more data has the more awesome things it
can do and yet at the other side people
imagine the worst case possible scenario
of what can you possibly do with that
data
people it's it goes down to trust as you
said
for there's a fundamental distrust of in
certain groups of governments and so on
and depending on the government
depending on who is in power depending
on all these kinds of factors and so
here's the lux in the middle of all of
it in the home trying to do good things
for the customers so how do you think
about privacy in this context the smart
assistants in the home how do you
maintain how do you earn trust
absolutely so as you said Trust is the
key here so you start with trust and
then privacy is a key aspect of it it
has to be designed from very beginning
about that and we believe in two
fundamental principles one is
transparency and second is control so if
by transparency I mean when we build
what is now called smart speaker or the
first echo we were quite judicious about
making these right trade-offs on
customers behalf that it is pretty clear
when when the audio is being sent the
cloud the light ring comes on when it
has heard you say the word wake word and
then the streaming happens right so and
the light ring comes up we also had we
put a physical mute button on it just so
you're if you didn't want it to be
listening even for the weak word then
you turn the power button on the mute
button on and that disables the
microphones that's just the first
decision on essentially transparency and
control over then even when we launched
we gave the control in the hands of the
customers that you can go and look at
any of your individual utterances that
is recorded and delete them anytime and
we have cut to true to that promise
right so and that is super again a great
instance of showing how you have the
control then we made it even easier you
can say lecture delete what I said today
so that is now making it even just just
more control in your hands with what's
most convenient about this technology is
voice you delete it with your voice now
so these are the types of decisions we
continually make we just recently
launched this feature called what we
think of it as if you wanted humans not
to review your data because smile you
mentioned supervised
so you in supervised learning humans
have to give some annotation and that
also is now a feature where you can
essentially if you selected that flag
your data will not be reviewed by a
human so these are the types of controls
that we have to constantly offer with
customers so why do you think about as
people so much that so that so
everything you just said is really
powerful to the control the ability to
leak because we collect we have studies
here running at MIT that collects huge
amounts of data and people consent and
so on the ability to delete that data is
really empowering and almost nobody ever
asked to delete it but the ability to
have that control is really powerful but
still you know there's these popular
anecdotes anecdotal evidence that people
say they like to tell that them and a
friend were talking about something I
don't know sweaters for cats and all
sudden they'll have advertisements for
cat sweaters on Amazon there's that
that's a popular anecdote as if
something is always listening
what can you explain that anecdote that
experience that people have what's the
psychology of that what's that
experience and can you you've answered
it but let me just ask is Alexa
listening no Alexa listens only for the
wake word on the device right and awake
word is the words like Alexa Amazon echo
and you but do you only choose one at a
time so you choose one and it listens
only for that on our devices so that's
first from a listening perspective we
have to be very clear that it's just the
wake word so you said why is there this
anxiety if you make yeah it's because
there's a lot of confusion what it
really listens to right and you and I
think it's partly on us to keep
educating our customers and the general
media more in terms of like how what
really happens and we've done a lot of
it and with our pages on information are
clear but still people have to have more
there's always a hunger for information
and clarity and will constantly look at
how best to communicate if you go back
and read everything yes it states
exactly that
and then people could still question it
and I think that's absolutely okay to
question what we have to make sure is
that we are because our fundamental
philosophy is customer first customer
obsession is our leadership principle if
you put as researchers I put myself in
the shoes of the customer and all
decisions in Amazon are made with that
and I throw and Trust has to be earned
and we have to keep earning the trust of
our customers in this setting and to
your other point on like is there
something showing up based on your
conversations no I think the answer is
like you a lot of times when those
experiences happen you have to also be
know that okay maybe a winter season
people are looking for sweaters right
and it shows up on your amazon.com
because it is popular so there are many
of these you mentioned that personality
or personalization turns out we are not
that unique either right so those things
we we as humans start thinking oh must
be because something was heard and
that's why this other thing showed up
the answer is no probably it is just the
season for sweaters I'm not gonna ask
you this question because it's just cuz
your doll so because people have so much
paranoia but for Milan as you say from
my perspective I hope there's a day when
customer can ask Alexa to listen all the
time to improve the experience to
improve because I personally don't see
the negative because if you have the
control and if you have the trust
there's no reason why I shouldn't be
listening all the time to the
conversations to learn more about you
because ultimately as long as you have
control and Trust every data you provide
to the device that the device wants is
going to be useful and that's it
to me I as a machine learning person I
think it worries me how sensitive people
are about their data relative to how
empowering it could be for the devices
around them how enriching it could be
for their own life to improve
the product so I just it's something I
think about sort of a lot how do we make
that devices obviously Lux that thinks
about it a lot as well I don't know if
you want to comment on that sort of okay
have you seen them in the form of a
question okay I have have you seen an
evolution in the way people think about
their private data in the previous
several years so as we as a society a
more more comfortable to the benefits we
get by sharing more data first let me
answer that part and then I'll want to
go back to the other aspect you were
mentioning so as a society on a general
we are getting more comfortable as a
society doesn't mean that everyone is
and I think we have to respect that
I don't think one-size-fits-all is
always gonna be the answer for all right
by definition so I think that's is
something to keep in mind in these going
back to your on what more magical
experiences can be launched in these
kind of AI settings I think again if you
give the control we it's possible
certain parts of it so if you have a
feature called follow-up mode where you
if you turn it on and Alexa after you've
spoken to it will open the mics again
thinking you lanced something again yeah
like if you're adding lists to your
shopping items so right or a shopping
list or to-do list
you're not done you want to keep so in
that setting it's awesome that it opens
the mic for you to say eggs and milk and
then bread right so these are the kind
of things which you can empower so I and
then another feature we have which is
called Alexa guard I said it only
listens for the wake word all right but
if you have a let's say you're going to
say Lex you leave your home and you want
a lexer to listen for a couple of sound
events like smoke alarm going off or
someone breaking your glass right so
it's like just to keep your peace of
mind so you can say Alexa on guard or
I'm away or and then it can be listening
for these sound events and when you're
home it you come out of that mode right
so this is another one where you again
gave controls in the hands of the user
or the custom
and to enable some experience that is
you higher utility and maybe even more
delightful in the certain settings like
follow up more and so forth again this
general principle is the same
control in the hands of the Castro so I
know we kind of started with a lot of
philosophy and a lot of interesting
topics and we'll just jumping all over
the place but really some of the
fascinating things at the alexa team and
Amazon's doings in the the algorithm
side the data side the technology at the
deep learning machine learning and and
so on so can you give a brief history of
Alexa from the perspective of just
innovation the algorithms the data of
how I was born how it came to be how is
grown where it is today yeah start with
in Amazon everything starts with the
customer and we have a process called
working backwards Alexa and more
specifically then the product echo there
was a working backwards document
essentially that reflected what it would
be started with a very simple vision
statement for instance that morphed into
a full-fledged document along the way
changed into what all it can do right
you can but the inspiration was the Star
Trek computer so when you think of it
that way you know everything is possible
but when you launch a product you have
to start with someplace and when I
joined we the product was already in
conception and we started working on the
far field speech recognition because
that was the first thing to solve by
that we mean that you should be able to
speak to the device from a distance and
in those days that wasn't a common
practice and even in the previous
research world I was in was considered
to an unsolvable problem then in terms
of whether you can converse from a
length and here I'm still talking about
the first part of the problem where you
say get the attention of the device as
in by saying what we call the wake word
which means the word Alexa has to be
detected with a very high accuracy
because it is a very common word it has
sound units that map with words like I
like you or Alec Alex
right so it's a undoubtably hard problem
to detect the right mentions of Alexa's
address to the device versus I like
Alexa you have to pick up that signal
when there's a lot of noise not only
noise north conversation they are in the
house while you remember on the device
you are simply listening for the wake
word Alexa and there's a lot of words
being spoken in the house how do you
know it's Alexa and directed at Alexa
because I could say I love my Alexa I
hate my Alex I want a lecture to do this
and in all these three sentences I said
Alexa I didn't want it to wake up yeah
so can I just pause on a second what
would be your device that I should
probably in the introduction of this
conversation give to people in terms of
with them turning off their Lutz a
device if they're listening to this
podcast conversation out loud like
what's the probability that an Alexa
device will go off because we mention
Alexa like a million times so it will we
have done a lot of different things
where we can figure out that there is
the device the speech is coming from a
human versus over there also I mean in
terms of like also it is think about ads
or so we have also launched a technology
for watermarking kind of approaches in
terms of filtering it out but yes if
this kind of a podcast is happening it's
possible your device will wake up a few
times it's an unsolved problem but it is
definitely something we care very much
about but the idea is you wanna detect
Alex were meant for the device or just
even hearing Alexa versus I like yeah
something I mean that's the fascinating
part so that was the first relief that's
the first of the world's best detector
of course
yeah the FIR world's best wait word
detector yeah in the far field setting
not like something where the phone is
sitting on the table this is like people
have devices 40 feet away like in my
house or 20 feet away and you still get
an answer so that was the first part the
next is
you're speaking to the device of course
you're gonna issue many different
requests some may be simple some may be
extremely hard but it's a large
vocabulary speech recognition problem
essentially where the audio is now not
coming on to your phone or a handheld
mic like this or close talking my but
it's from 20 feet away where if you're
in a busy household your son may be
listening to music your daughter may be
running around with something and asking
your mom something and so forth
right so this is like a common household
setting where the words you're speaking
to Alexa
need to be recognized with very high
accuracy yes right now we are still just
in the recognition problem you haven't
yet come to the understanding one writes
in if a possum so I once again what year
was this is this before neural networks
began to start to seriously prove
themselves in audio space yeah this is
around so I joined in 2013 in April
right so the early research in neural
networks coming back and showing some
promising results in speech recognition
space had started happening but it was
very early yeah but we just took now
build on that on the very first thing we
did when when I join and we with the
team and remember it was a very smudge
of a start-up environment which is great
about Amazon and we double down on deep
learning right away and we we knew will
have to improve accuracy fast and
because of that we worked on and the
scale of data once you have a device
like this if it is successful will
improve big time like you'll suddenly
have large volumes of data to learn from
to make the customer experience better
so how do you scale deep learning so we
did are one of the first works in in
training with distributed GPUs and where
the training time was you know was
linear in terms of like in the amount of
data so that was quite important work
where it was algorithmic improvements as
well as a lot of engineering
improvements to be able to train on
thousands and thousand of speech and
that was an important factor so the if
you ask me like
back in 2013 and 2014 when we launched
echo the combination of large scale data
deep learning progress near infinite GPX
we had available on AWS even then was
all came together for us to be able to
solve the far field speech recognition
to the extent it could be useful to the
customers it still not solved like I
mean it's not that we are perfect at
recognizing speech but we are great at
it in terms of the settings that are in
homes right so and that was important
even in the early stages the first even
I'm trying to look back at that time if
I remember correctly that it was it
seems like the task will be pretty
daunting so like so we kind of take it
for granted that it works now yes right
so let me like how first time you
mentioned startup I wasn't familiar how
big the team was I kind of because I
know there's a lot of really smart
people working on looks and I was very
very large team how big was the team how
likely were you to fail in the highs of
everyone else like what I'll give you a
very interesting anecdote on that when I
joined the team the speech recognition
team was six people my first meeting and
we had hired a few more people it was 10
people 9 out of 10 people thought it
can't be done who was the one the one
was me and actually I should say and one
was say my optimistic yeah and and 8th
we're trying to convince let's go to the
management and say let's not work on
this problem let's work on some other
problem like either telephony speech for
customer service calls and so forth but
this was the kind of belief you must
have and I had experience with far-field
speech recognition and I my eyes lit up
and I saw a problem like that saying
okay we have been in speech recognition
always looking for that killer app and
this was a killer use case to bring
something delightful in the hands of
customers you mentioned you the way kind
of think of
the product way in the future have a
press release and an FAQ and you think
backwards that's did you have that the
team have the echo and mind
so this far-field speech recognition
actually putting a thing in the home
that works it's able to interact with
was that the press release what was the
way close I would say in terms of the as
I said the vision was started computer
right or the inspiration and from there
I can't divulge all the exact
specifications but one of the first
things that was magical on a lexer was
music it brought me to back to music
because my taste was still and when I
was an undergrad right so I still listen
to those songs and I it was too hard for
me to be a music fan with a phone right
so I and I don't I hate things in my
ears so from that perspective it was
quite hard and and and music was part of
the at least the documents I have seen
right so so from that perspective I
think yes in terms of our how far are we
from the original vision I can't reveal
that words that's why I have done a fun
at work because every day we go in and
thinking like these are the new set of
challenges to solve yeah that's a great
way to do great engineering is you think
of the product press release I like that
idea
maybe we'll talk about it a bit later
was just a super nice way to have
focused I'll tell you this you're a
scientist and a lot of my scientists
have adopted that they they have now
they love it as a process because it was
very a scientist you're trained to write
great papers but they are all after
you've done the research or you're
proven lie and your PhD dissertation
proposal is something that comes closest
or a DARPA proposal or NSF proposal is
the closest that comes to a press
release but that process is now
ingrained in our scientists which is
like delightful for me to see you write
the paper first then make it happen
that's right in fact that's not
state-of-the-art results or you leave
the results section open well you have a
thesis about here's what I expect right
and here's what it will change
Yeah right so I think it is a great
thing it works for researchers as well
they're so far field recognition yeah
what was the big leap what what were the
breakthroughs and yeah what was that
journey liked it today yeah I think the
as you said first there was a lot of
skepticism on whether far-field speech
recognition will ever work to be good
enough right and what we first did was
got a lot of training data in a far
field setting and that was extremely
hard to get because none of it existed
so how do you collect data in far field
set up right with no customer bases
there's no customer base right so that
was first innovation and once we had
that the next thing was ok you if you
have the data first of all we didn't
talk about like what would magical mean
in this kind of a setting what is good
enough for customers right that's always
since you've never done this before what
would be magical so so it wasn't just a
research problem you had to put some in
terms of accuracy and customer
experience features some stakes on the
ground saying here is where I think
should it should get to so you
established a bar and then how do you
measure progress toward is given you
have no customer right now so from that
perspective we went so first was the
data without customers second was
doubling down on deep learning as a way
to learn and I can just tell you that
the combination of the two cut our error
rates by a factor of five from where we
were when I started to within six months
of having that data we at that point and
I got the conviction that this will work
right so because that was magical in
terms of when it started working and
that reached them who came close to the
magical bar back to the bar right that
we felt would be where people will use
it that was critical because you you
really have one chance at this if we had
launched in November 2014 years when we
launched and if it was below the bar I
don't think this category exists if you
don't need the bar
yeah and just having looked at
voice-based interactions like in the car
or earlier systems it's a source of huge
frustration for people in fact we use
voice based interaction for collecting
data on subjects to measure frustration
so as a training set for computer vision
for face data so we can get a data set
of frustrated people that's the best way
to get frustrated people is having them
interact with a voice based system in
the car so this is that bar I imagine
it's pretty high it was very high and we
talked about how also errors are
perceived from a eyes versus errors by
humans but we are not done with the
problems that ended up we had to solve
to get it to launch so do you want the
next one so the next one was what I
think of as multi-domain
natural language understanding it's very
I wouldn't say easy but it is during
those days solving it understanding in
one domain and narrow domain was doable
but for these multiple domains like
music like information other kinds of
household productivity alarms time
errors even though it wasn't as big as
it is in terms of the number of skills
alexa has and the confusion space has
like grown by three orders of magnitude
it was still daunting even those days
and again no customer base here again no
customer base so now you're looking at
meaning understanding and intent
understanding and taking actions on
behalf of customers based on their
request and that is the next hard
problem even if you have gotten the
words recognized how do you make sense
of them in those days there was still a
lot of emphasis on rule-based systems
for writing grammar patterns to
understand the intent but we had a
statistical first approach even then
where for a language understanding we
had in even those starting days and an
entity recognizer and an intent
classifier which was all trained
statistically in fact we had to build
the
deterministic matching as follow-up to
fix bugs that statistical models have
right so it was just a different mindset
where we focused on data-driven
statistical understanding wins in the
end if you have a huge dataset yes it is
contingent on that and that's why it
came back to how do you get the data
before customers the fact that this is
why data becomes crucial to get a to the
point that you have the understanding
system built in build up and notice that
for here we were talking about human
machine dialogue even those early days
even it was very much transactional do
one thing one shot a transition great
way there was a lot of debate on how
much should Alex our talk back in terms
of if you misunderstood you or you said
play songs by the stones and let's say
it doesn't know you know early days
knowledge can be sparse who were the
stones right I the Rolling Stones right
so our and you don't want them match to
be Stone Temple Pilots or Rolling Stones
right so you don't know which one it is
so these kind of other signals to know
there we had great assets right from
Amazon in terms of you acts like what is
it what kind of yeah hurry solve that
problem in terms of what we think of it
as an entity resolution problem right so
is one is it right I mean the even if
you figured out the stones is an entity
you have to resolve it to whether it's
the stones or the temple violence or
some other stones maybe I misunderstood
is the resolution the job of the
algorithm or is the job of UX
communicating with the human to help
there as well there is both right it is
law you want 90 percent or high 90s to
be done without any further questioning
or UX right so but that it's absolutely
okay just like as humans we asked the
question I didn't understand your likes
yeah it's fine for a lecture to
occasionally say I did not understand
you right and and that's a important way
to learn and I'll talk about where we
have come with more self learning with
these kind of feedback signals
but in those days just solving the
ability of understanding the intent and
resolving to an action where action
could be play a particular artist or a
particular song was super hot again -
the bar was high as as you're talking
about right so while we launched it in
sort of 13 big domains I would say in
terms of or thing we think of it as 13
the big skills we had like music is a
massive one when we launched it and now
we have 90,000 plus skills on Alexa so
what are the big skills can you just go
is the only thing I use it for is music
weather and shopping haha so we think of
it as music information right so it's
all whether it's a part of information
right so then we launched we didn't have
smart home but within spikes bottom I
mean you connect your smart devices you
control them with watch if you haven't
done it it's worth it will change your
signing on the lights
yeah you like to do anything that's
connected and has a it's just what your
favorite smart device for you and now
you've the smart plug with and you don't
we also have this echo plug which is oh
yeah and now you can turn on that one on
and off this conversation motivation in
Kevin's garage door you can check your
status of the garage door and things
like and we have gone may collect some
more and more proactive where it even
have a hunt has on chores now that all
those hunches like you left your light
on or let's say you've gone to your bed
and you left the garage light on so yeah
it will help you out in these settings
right so that smart devices right
information smart devices said music
yeah so I don't remember everything we
had big ones like that was you know the
timers were very popular right away
music also like you could play song
artist album everything and so that was
like a clear win in terms of the
customer experience so that's again this
is language understanding now things
have evolved right so where we want a
lecture definitely to be more accurate
competent and trustworthy based on how
well it does these core things but we
have
in many different dimensions first is
what I think of her doing more
conversational for high-utility not just
for chat right and there we a tree Mars
this year which is our AI conference we
launched what is called Alexa
conversations that is providing the
ability for developers to author
multi-tone experiences on Alexa with no
code essentially in terms of the code
dialogue code initially it was like you
know all these IVR systems you have to
fully author if the customer says this
do that right so the whole dialogue flow
is hand author and with Alexa
conversations the way it is that you
just provide a sample interaction data
with your service or an API let's say
you're Adam take its that provides a
service for buying movie tickets you
provide a few examples of how your
customers will interact with your api's
and then the dialogue flow is
automatically constructed using a
recurrent neural network a train on that
beta so that simplifies the developer
experience we just launched our preview
for the developers to try this
capability out and then the second part
of it which shows even increased utility
for customers is you and I when we
interact with Alexa or any customer as I
coming back to our initial part of the
conversation the goal is often unclear
or unknown to the AI if I say Alexa what
movies are playing nearby am i trying to
just buy movie tickets am I actually
even do you think I'm looking for just
movies for curiosity whether the
Avengers are still in theater or when
it's maybe it's gone and maybe it will
come on my mr. so I may watch it on
prime which happened to me so so from
that perspective now you're looking into
what is my goal and let's say I now
complete the movie ticket purchase maybe
I would like to get dinner nearby so
what is really the goal here is it night
out or is it movies as and just go watch
a movie here the answer is we don't know
so can Alexa now figure we have the
intelligence that I think this metal
goal is really night or at least say to
the customer when you have completed the
purchase of movie tickets from Adam
tickets or Fandango or picture anyone
then the next thing is do you want to
get to get an uber to the theater right
or do you want to book a restaurant next
to it and and then not ask the same
information over and over again what
time what how many people in your party
right so so this is where you shift the
cognitive burden from the customer to
the AI where it's thinking the of what
is your it anticipates your goal and
takes the next best action to complete
it now that's the machine learning
problem but essentially you're the way
we solve this first instance and we have
a long way to go to make it scale to
everything possible in the world but at
least for this situation it is from at
every instance Alexa is making the
determination whether it should stick
with the experience with Adam tickets or
offer or you based on what you say
whether either you have completed the
interaction or you said no get me an
uber now so it will shift context into
another experience or skill on another
service so that's a dynamic
decision-making that's making Alexa you
can say more conversational for the
benefit of the customer rather than
simply complete transactions which are
well thought through if you as a
customer has fully specified what you
want to be accomplished its
accomplishing that so it's kind of as I
would do this with pedestrians like
intent modeling is predicting what your
possible goals are most likely going and
switching that depending on the things
you say so my question is there it seems
maybe it's a dumb question but it would
help a lot of elects remembered me what
I said previously right
it is it's trying to use some memory for
the custom year it is using a lot of
memory within that so right now not so
much in terms of okay which restaurant
do you prefer right that is a more
long-term memory but within the
short-term memory within the session it
is remembering how many people did you
so if you said buy four tickets not has
made an implicit assumption that you
were gonna have you need for at least
four seats at a restaurant right so
these are the kind of context its
preserving between these skills but
within that session what are you asking
the right question in terms of for it to
be more and more useful it has to have
more long-term memory and that's also an
open question and again this is still
early days so for me I mean everybody is
different but yeah I'm definitely not
representative of the general population
the sense that I do the same thing every
day like I eat the same that I do
everything the same the same thing we're
the same thing clearly this or the black
shirt so it's frustrating when it looks
it doesn't get what I'm saying because I
had to correct her every time the exact
same way this has to do with certain
songs like she doesn't know certain
weird songs only and doesn't know I've
complained to Spotify about this talked
to the Rd head of our idea Spotify
stairway to heaven I have to correct it
every time it really doesn't play Led
Zeppelin correctly so I should figure
you should send me or next time it fails
the seat for you to send it to me we'll
take care of it okay well let's Apple it
is one of my favorite it works for me so
I'm like shocked it doesn't work for you
this is an official public port I'll put
it I'll make it public retweet it we're
gonna fix this there would have
impairment
anyway but the point is you know I'm
pretty boring and do the same thing but
I'm sure most people do the same set of
things do you see Alexa sort of
utilizing that in the future for
improving the experience yes and not
only utilizing it's already doing some
of it we call it where Alexa is becoming
more self learning so Alexa is now auto
correcting millions and millions of car
trances in US without any human
supervision
the way desert is let's take an example
of a particular song didn't work for you
what do you do next you either
it played the wrong song and you said
Alexa no that's not the song I want or
you say likes a play that you try it
again
and that is a signal to Alexa that she
may have done something wrong and from
that perspective we can learn if there's
that failure pattern or that action of
song a was played when song B was
requested yes it's very common with
station names because play NPR you can
have n be confused as an M and then you
for a certain accent like mine
people confuse my n and M all the time
and because I will Indian accent there
confusable to humans it is for Alexa too
and in that part but it starts auto
correcting and we collect we correct a
lot of these automatically without a
human looking at the failures so the one
of the things that's for me missing in
Alessa I don't know from a
representative customer but every time I
correct it it would be nice to know that
that made a difference yes you know I
mean like that yeah sort of like I I
heard you like some acknowledgement of
that we worked a lot with with Tesla
study the autopilot and so on and a
large amount of the customers they used
Tesla autopilot they feel like they're
always teaching the system uh-huh
they're almost excited by the
possibility teaching I don't know if
Alexa customers generally think of it as
they're teaching to improve the system I
think and that's a really powerful thing
against I would say it's a spectrum some
customers do think that way and some
would be annoyed by Alexa acknowledging
that or so there's a again no one you
know while there are certain patterns
not everyone is the same in this way but
we believe that again customers helping
Alexa is a tenet for us in terms of
improving it dancing more self learning
is by again this is like fully
unsupervised right there is no you
in the loop and no labeling happening
and based on your actions as a customer
Alexa becomes smarter again it's early
days but I think this whole area of
teachable AI is gonna get bigger and
bigger in the whole space especially in
the AI assistant space so that's the
second part where I mentioned more
conversational this is more self
learning the third is more natural and
the way I think of more natural is we
talked about how Alexa sounds and there
are and we have done lot of advances in
our text to speech by using again neural
network technology for it to sound very
human like an individual texture the
sound to the the the timing the tonality
tone of everything
I would think in terms of there's a lot
of controls in each of the places for
how I mean the speed of the voice the
prosthetic patterns the the actual
smoothness of how it sounds all of those
are factored and we do ton of listening
tests to make sure is that what
naturalness how it sounds should be very
natural how it understands requests is
also very important like and in terms of
like we have 95,000 skills or and if we
have imagined that and many of these
skills you have to remember the skin
Ling and say Alexa asked they're tied
skill to tell me X right or now if you
have to remove the skill name that means
the discovery and the interaction is
unnatural and we're trying to solve that
by what we think of as again this was
you don't have to have the app metaphor
here these are not individual apps right
even though they're so you cut you're
not sort of opening one at a time and
interacting so yeah it should be
seamless because it's voice and when
it's voice you have to be able to
understand these requests independent of
the specificity like a scale name and to
do that what we have done is again built
a deep learning based capability where
we shot list a bunch of skills when you
say Alexa get me a car and then we
figure it out okay it may it's meant for
a nubile skill versus a left or they
on your preferences and then you can
rank the responses from the scale and
then choose the best response for the
customer so that's on the more natural
other examples of more natural is like
we were talking about lists for instance
and you wanna you don't want to say
Alexa add milk likes to add eggs Alexa
hired cookies you know Alexa add cookies
milk and eggs and that in one shot right
so that works that helps with the
naturalness we talked about memory like
if you said you can say like so remember
I have to go to Mom's house or you may
have entered a calendar event through
your calendar that's linked or like so
you don't remember whether it's in my
calendar or did I tell you how to
remember something or some other
reminder right so you have to now
independent of how customers create
these events it should just say Alexa
when do I have to go to Mom's house and
it tells you when you have to go to
Mom's house that's the fascinating
problem who's that problem on so the
these people create skills uh-huh who's
who's tasked with integrating all of
that knowledge together so if the skills
becomes seamless is it the creators of
the skills sewer system the
infrastructure that Alexa provides
problem it's both I think the large
problem in terms of making sure your
skill quality is high we that has to be
done by our tools because it's just so
these skills just to put the context
they are built through Alexa skill scale
which is a self-serve way of building an
experience on Alexa this is like any
developer in the world could go to Alexa
scale skate and build an experience on
Alex like if you're a dominoes you can
build a domino skills for instance that
does pizza ordering when you've authored
that you do want to now if people say
like so open Domino's or Alexa ask
dominoes dominoes to get a particular
type of pizza that will work but the
discovery is harder you can't just say
like so get me a pizza and then Alexa
figures out what to do that latter part
is definitely our responsibility in
terms of when the request is not Feliz
how do you figure out what's the best
skill or a service that can fulfill the
customer's request and it can keep
evolving imagine going to the situation
I said which was the night out planning
that it the goal could be more than that
individual request that came a Pizza
ordering could mean a night in event
with your kids in the house and your so
this is welcome to the world of
conversational yeah this is this is
super exciting because it's not the
academic problem of NLP of natural
language processing understanding
dialogue this is like real world the
stakes are high in a sense that
customers get frustrated quickly people
get frustrated quickly so you have to
get it right if to get that interaction
right so it's I love it but so from that
perspective what what are the challenges
today what what are the problems that
really need to be solved and yes here's
I think first and foremost as I
mentioned that get the basics right are
still true basically even the one-shot
requests which we think of as
transactional requests needs to work
magically no question about that lee if
it doesn't turn your light on and off
you'll be super frustrated even if I can
complete the night out for you and not
do that that is unacceptable for as a
customer right so that you have to get
the foundational understanding going
very well the second aspect when I said
more conversational is as you imagine is
more about reasoning it is really about
figuring out what the latent goal is of
the customer based on what I have the
information now and the history and
what's the next best thing to do so
that's a complete reasoning and
decision-making problem just like your
self-driving car but the goal is still
more finite here it
Evos your environment is super hard and
self-driving and the cost of a mistake
is huge here but there are certain
similarities but if you think about how
many decisions Alexa is making or
evaluating at any given time it's a huge
hypothesis space and we're only talked
about so far about what I think of
reactive to
in terms of you asked for something and
Alexis reacting to it if you bring the
proactive part which is Alexa having
hunches so any given instance then your
it's really a decision at any given
point based on the information Alexa has
to determine what's the best thing it
needs to do so these are the ultimate AI
problem well decisions based on the
information you have do you think my
prospectus a lot I work a lot with
sensing of the human face do you think
they'll and we touch this topic a little
bit earlier but do you think it'll be a
day soon when Alexa can also look at you
to help improve the quality of the hunch
it has or at least detect frustration or
detects you know improve the quality of
its perception of what you what you're
trying to do I mean let me again bring
back to what it already does we talked
about how based on you bargain over
Alexa clearly it's a very high
probability it must have done something
wrong that's why you understand the next
extension of whether frustration is a
signal or not of course is a natural
thought in terms of how that should be
in a signal to egg you can get that from
voice you can get from voice but it's
very hard like I mean a frustration as a
signal historically if you think about
emotions of different kinds you know
there's a whole field of affective
computing something that MIT has also
done a lot of research and is super hot
and you are now talking about a far
field device as in you're talking to a
distance noisy environment and in that
environment it needs to have a good
sense for your emotions this is a very
very hard problem very hard problem but
you haven't shadow voice from hard
problems well you know so deep learning
has been at the core of a lot of this
technology are you optimistic about the
current deep learning approaches to
solving the hardest aspects of what
we're talking about or do you think
there will come a time where new ideas
need to for this you know if you look at
reasoning so opening eye deep mind a lot
of folks are now starting to work in
reasoning trying to see how can make
neural networks a reason do you see that
new approaches need to be invented to
take the next big leap absolutely I
think there has to be a lot more
investment and I think in many different
ways and there are these I would say
nuggets of research forming in a good
way like learning with less data or like
zero short learning one-shot learning
and the active learning stuff you've
talked about is yes incredible since so
transfer learning is also super critical
especially when you're thinking about
applying knowledge from one task to
another or one language to another right
it's really ripe so these are great
pieces deep learning has been useful too
and now we are sort of marrying deep
learning with with transfer learning an
active learning of course that's more
straightforward in terms of applying
deep learning and an active learning set
up but but I do think in terms of now
looking into more reasoning based
approaches is going to be key for our
next wave of the technology but there is
a good news the good news is that I
think for keeping on to delight
customers that a lot of it can be done
by prediction tasks yes so and so we
haven't exhausted that so we don't need
to give up on the deep learning
approaches for that so that's just I
wanted sort of the query on our rich
fulfilling amazing experience that makes
Amazon a lot of money and a lot of
everybody a lot of money because it does
awesome things deep learning is enough
the the point the point I don't think I
would say deep learning is enough I
think for the purposes of Alexa
accomplish the task for customers I'm
saying there are still a lot of things
we can do with prediction based
approaches that do not reason right I'm
not saying that
and we haven't exhausted those but for
the kind of high utility experiences
that I'm personally passionate about of
what Alexa needs to do reasoning has to
be solved today to the same extent as
you can think of
naturally understanding and a speech
recognition to the extent of
understanding intents has been how
accurate it has become but reasoning we
are very very early days the nest
another way how hard of a problem do you
think that is hardest of them I would
say hardest of them because again the
hypothesis space of is really really
large and when you go back in time like
you were saying I wanna I want Alexei to
remember more things that once you go
beyond a session of interaction which is
my session I mean a a time span which is
today two versus remembering which
restaurant I like and then when I'm
planning a night out to say do you want
to go to the same restaurant now you're
up the steaks big time and and this is
where the reasoning dimension also goes
very very big so you think the space
will be elaborating that a little bit
just philosophically speaking do you
think when you reason about trying to
model what the goal of a person is in
the context of interacting with Alexa
you think that space is huge it's huge
absolutely you think so like another a
devil's advocate would be that we human
beings are really simple and we all want
like just a small set of things and
they're so do you think you think it's
possible cuz we're not talking about a
fulfilling general conversation perhaps
actually the Alexa prize is a little bit
after that creating a customer like
there's so many of the interactions it
feels like are clustered in groups that
are don't require general reasoning I
think you're you right in terms of the
head of the distribution of all the
possible things customers may want to
accomplish but the tail is long and it's
diverse right so from many many long
tails from that perspective I think you
have to solve that problem otherwise and
everyone's very different like I mean we
see this already in terms of the skills
right I mean if you if you're an average
surfer which I am now
right but somebody is asking Alexa about
surfing conditions right and there's a
skill that is there for them to get to
right that tells you that the tail is
massive like in terms of like what kind
of skills people have created it's
humongous in terms of it and which means
there are these diverse needs and and
when you start looking at the
combinations of these right even if your
pairs of skills and and 90000 choose two
it's still a big concept of combination
so I'm saying there's a huge to do here
now and I think customers are you know
wonderfully frustrated with things and
then I'm gonna keep getting to do better
things for that so and they're not known
to be super patient so you have to do it
fast you have to do it fast yeah so
you've mentioned the idea of a press
release the research and development
Amazon Alexa and Amazon in general you
kind of think of what the future product
will look like and you kind of make it
happen you work backwards
so can you draft for me you probably
have one paquimé makeup on for 10 20 30
40 years out that you see the Alexa team
putting out just in broad strokes
something that you dream about I think
let's start with the five years first
okay so and I'll get to the Fortius
through in broad strokes this term I
think the five year is where I mean I
think of in these spaces it's hard
especially if you're in thick of things
to think beyond the five year space
because a lot of things change right I
mean if you ask me five years back will
Alexa will be here I wouldn't have I
think it has surpassed my imagination of
that time right so I think then from the
next five years perspective from a AI
perspective what we're gonna see is that
notion which you said goal-oriented
dialogues and open domain like Alec
surprised I think that bridge is gonna
get closed they won't be different and
I'll give you why that's the case
you mentioned shop
how do you shop do you shop in in one
shot sure your double-a batteries paper
towels yes how much how long does it
take for you to buy a camera you do ton
of research yeah then you make a
decision so is there is that a goal
oriented a lot dialogue when I like
somebody says Alexa find me a camera is
it simply in cue sitive ness right so
even in this something that you think of
it as shopping which you said you
yourself use a lot off if you go beyond
where it's reorders or items where you
sort of not brand conscious and so forth
that was just in shock just to comment
quickly I've never bought in you think
through Alexa there haven't bought
before on Amazon on a desktop after I
clicked in a bunch you read a much
reviews that kind of stuff so it's
repurchase so now you think in even for
something that you felt like is is a
finite goal I think the space is huge
because even products the attributes are
many like and you want to look at
reviews some on Amazon some outside some
you want to look at what Zenit is saying
or another consumer forum is saying
about even a product for instance right
so that's just that's just shopping
where you could you could argue the
ultimate goal is sort of known and we
haven't talked about Alexa what's the
weather in Cape Cod this weekend right
so why am I asking that weather question
right so I think I think of it as how do
you complete goals with minimum steps
for our customers right and when you
think of it that way the distinction
between goal-oriented and conversations
for open domain say goes away I may want
to know what happened in the
presidential debate right and is it I'm
seeking just information on I'm looking
at who's winning winning the debates
right so these are all quite hard
problems so even the five-year horizon
problem I'm like I sure hope we'll solve
these new year you're optimistic because
that's the hard problem
which part the reasoning you know enough
to be able to help explore complex goals
that are beyond something simplistic
that feels like it could be well five
years is a nice it's a nice bar form
right I think you will
it's a like nice ambition and do we have
press releases for that absolutely can I
tell you what specifically the roadmap
will be no right and what and will be
solve all of it in the five-year space
now this is we will work on this forever
actually if we this is the hardest of
the eye problems and I don't see if that
being solved even in a 40 year horizon
because even if you limit to the human
intelligence we know we are quite far
from that in fact every aspects of our
sensing to do neural processing to how
brain stores information and how it
processes it we don't yet know how to
represent knowledge all right so we're
and still in those are early stages so I
wanted to start that's why at the
five-year yeah because the five-year
success would look like that and solving
these complex goals and the forty year
would be where it's just natural to talk
to these in terms of more of these
complex goals right now we've already
come to the point where these
transactions you mentioned of asking for
weather or reordering something or
listening to your favorite tune it's
natural for you to actually say it's
it's now unnatural to pick up your phone
right and that I think is the first
five-year transformation the next five
your transformation would be okay I can
plan my weekend with Alexa or I can plan
my next meal with Alexa or my next night
out with seamless effort so just to
pause and look back at the big picture
of it all
it's a you're part of a large team
that's creating a system that's in the
home that's not human that gets to
interact with human beings
so we human beings we these descendants
of apes have created an artificial
intelligence system that's able to have
conversations I mean that that to me the
two most
transformative robots of this century I
think will be autonomous vehicles but
they're a little bit transforming from a
more boring way it's like a tool I think
conversational agents in the home is I
can experience how does that make you
feel the year at the center of creating
that as its do you sit back and awe
sometimes what what it what is your what
is your feeling about the whole mess of
it can you even believe that we're able
to create something like this I think
it's a privilege I'm so fortunate like
where where I ended up right and and
it's been a long journey like I've been
in this space for a long time in
Cambridge right and it's it's so
heartwarming to see the kind of adoption
conversational agents are having now
five years back it was almost like
should I move out of this because we are
unable to find this killer application
that customers would love that would not
simply be good to have thing in research
labs and it's so fulfilling to see it
make a difference to millions and
billions of people a worldwide the good
thing is they're still very early so I
have another 20 years of job security
doing what I love like so I think from
that perspective I feel I tell every
researcher this that joins or every
member of my team this is a unique
privilege like I think and we have and I
would say not just launching a lecture
in 2014 which was first of its kind
along the way we have when we launch a
lecture skills get it become became
democratizing AI when before that there
was no good evidence often SDK for
speech and language now we are coming to
this very you and I'm having this
conversation where I'm not saying Oh
legs planning a night out with an AI
agent impossible I'm saying it's in the
realm of possibility and not only
possible we will be launching this right
so some elements of that every and it
will keep getting better we know that is
a universal truth once you have these
kind of agents out there being
use they get better for your customers
and I think that's where I think the
amount of research topics we are
throwing out at our budding researchers
is just gonna be exponentially hard and
the great thing is you can now get
immense satisfaction by having costumers
use it not just a paper and new reps or
another conference I think everyone
myself included are deeply excited about
that future so that I don't think
there's a better place to and Rohit
thank you thank you so much this was fun
thank you same here thanks for listening
to this conversation with rohit prasad
and thank you to our presenting sponsor
cash app downloaded use coal export cast
you'll get ten dollars and $10 will go
to first stem education nonprofit and
inspires hundreds of thousands of young
minds to learn and to dream of
engineering our future if you enjoy this
podcast subscribe on youtube give it
five stars an apple podcast supported on
patreon or connect with me on twitter
and now let me leave you with some words
of wisdom from the great alan turing
sometimes is the people no one can
imagine anything of who do the things no
one can imagine thank you for listening
and hope to see you next time
you